what doesn't seem to be going away is
that it isn't just sexual harassment but
also racial incidents at Fox News Fox
News is now being accused sued in fact
by nine black employees for racial
discrimination two black employees were
already suing Fox News because of
alleged racist comments and actions by
Fox News controller Judy Slater an
accounting director Tammy Effinger
Slater was fired last month after an
initial investigation ëthe injure has
yet to be removed seven new Fox News
employees have also joined the lawsuit
now which alleges that these two women
subjected black employees to racial
insults for years and that their
superiors did little about it allegedly
Slater would call black men wife beaters
and say that black people want to harm
white people it also alleges that Slater
forced black and white female employees
to fight and to arm-wrestle each other
to see which race would win I mean these
are seriously bizarre allegations and
indeed indicative of very significant
depravity if true and the suit says that
the other woman Effinger would just
stand back and laugh as all of this was
going on allegedly and completely
unsurprisingly this would all take place
outside of Roger Ailes his office when
he was still employed at Fox News the
suit says that Effinger would often brag
about wanting to fight a black employee
these people being accused aren't even
political commentators we're talking
about like the accounting department of
Fox News and a lot of people in our
audience don't like Fox News editorially
or for propagandistic reasons but it
increasingly appears that the network is
toxic on many and and it bizarre levels
that we didn't previously understand the
image of the channel is completely
deteriorating I read a report yesterday
on the way here to the conference in Las
Vegas that morale is just very low at
Fox News that some of the top
executives are not attending as
regularly as they once were like they're
just kind of missing in action not good
not good what's going on at Fox News and
I really don't care very much I mean
it's been bad over there for a while and
it seems that this may be their just
desserts so to speak but we'll continue
following it we'll continue following
the lawsuit and is anyone really
surprised at these allegations I mean
when I read about it it completely
seemed like kind of the obvious thing it
would be rare to me but Fox News only
has problems with how they treat women
that I would be very very surprised if
it was limited to that